we are loving been as the new bachelor
his debut last night was a hit but hold
on now we have uncovered something it's
been a hypocrite hello because remember
Nancy he told us he wanted to hold off
on the physical stuff he's stressed
again last night on the show but then my
man here is so busted yeah because what
the episode did show you was been
locking lips with the dentist lady come
on now and I got the chance to grill Ben
about that I said Ben you got some
explaining to do you know talk about all
that craziness going on when he stopped
by here today I wanted the first you got
it everybody so unicorns do exist I
picked it out of my garden for you maybe
if things go well tonight you can
pollinate it later
Pinterest yeah swing can you eat there
yeah you can't beat this the limo exits
last night we're classic the unicorn
head the mini horse the onesie and Mandy
she was giving you this oral exam but he
she intrigued me and I want to get to
know her better she was not only upfront
about you know her feelings but she was
also a little aggressive in how she
approached the night she wasn't nervous
and I thought those are all things that
I was intrigued by 7.5 million watched
the premiere with pretty much everybody
agreeing this bachelor is sweet sincere
and the perfect been interested in what
makes up the women not just make it out
but have we caught him being a little
bit of a hypocrite you made a comment
about how now I'm going to get to know
you the ladies before I live long yeah
then then we see this shot up on the PR
thing of you lip-locking
so did Mandy wasn't planning to do right
I do so this looks a lot different than
it actually was
yeah why were the cut out of the show
that shot makes it look a lot more than
it really was it was like a a peck
it's crazy she hit me in the face oh I'm
so unders think it Newton is hurt oh I
am in love with two women here I just
didn't realize how hard this is gonna
get fifty shades are crazy post Chris
Harrison calls this the most dramatic
season in bachelor history and fantasy
bachelor leagues yep those really do
exist are already eaten up with people
getting points for things like who gets
visibly drunk who has a body part blurt
out who rides in a helicopter and of
course who wins I don't know if you know
this but kaley cuoco you know the
actress under Big Bang Theory and her
sister Ruby instagrammed a little
something along with a video they
actually wrote those damn twins took our
spot I don't know nervous me lines are
closed this is Kaylee's newly single so
if you're not taken haha
what'd you think about Kaylee you know
she's a beautiful beautiful person so
you wouldn't mind going out with her
let's not jump to conclusion